from the time that there is an awareness
of the existence of the soul
we'll say circa 50,000 BP until the
resolution of the apocalyptic potential
there's something like 50,000 years
which in biological time is only a
moment but it is the entire span of
history times 5 in that period
everything hangs in the balance because
it is a mad rush from monkey them to
Starship hood and in the leap across
those 25,000 years energies are released
religions are shot off like Sparks
philosophies evolve and die science
arises magic arises all of these things
which control power with greater and
lesser degrees of ethical constancy
appear there is the possibility as in
the metaphor of dying there is the
possibility of mucking it up of
aborting the species transformation into
a hyperspatial intellect we are now
there can be no doubt that we are now in
final seconds of that crisis the crisis
which involves the end of history the
departure from the planet the triumph
over death and the release of the
individuals from matter we are in fact
closing distance with the most profound
event the planetary ecology can
encounter which is the freeing of life
from the dark chrysalis of matter the
old metaphor of psyche as the butterfly
is a species wide metaphor we must
undergo a metamorphosis in order to
survive the momentum of the historical
forces already in motion well if you
know anything about evolutionary biology
you know that man is considered to be an
unevolved in species in other words
sometime in the last hundred thousand
years with the invention of culture the
the biological evolution of man ceased
and evolution became a cultural
phenomenon
tools languages and philosophies began
to evolve that the human soul type began
to remain the same and so we're very
much like people a long time ago but
technology is the real skin of our
species man
correctly seen in the context of the
last 500 years is an extruder of a
technological shell we take in matter
that has a low degree of organization we
put it through mental filters and we
extrude linda's line gospel's space
shuttles all of these things this is
what we do we're like coral animals
embedded in a technological brief of
extruded psychic objects in other words
the body must become an interior eyes
hologrammatic object embedded in a
solid-state hyper dimensional matrix
which is eternal so that man wanders
through Elysium in his body experiencing
all the pleasures of the flesh but not
realizing that he is a holographic
projection of a solid-state matrix that
is micro miniaturized superconducting
and nowhere to be found it is part of
the plenum and we all history is about
producing prototypes of this situation
with greater and greater closure toward
the ideal so that airplanes automobiles
condominiums space shuttles space
colonies of starships of the hardware
speed of light spin dizzy drive type all
of these are as Marcy Leon says
self-transforming images of flight that
speak volumes about man's aspiration to
self transcendence so that we are our
wish our salvation and our only hope
basically is to end the historical
crisis by becoming the alien by ending
alienation by recognize the alien as the
self in fact
and all these other images the starship
the space colony all that these are
precursors again the idea that history
is the shockwave of eschatology as you
close distance with the eschatological
object the reflections it is throwing
off become more and more true to the
thing itself and in the final moment God
stands revealed there are no more
reflections of the mystery the mystery
and all its nakedness then is seen and
nothing else exists